hello and welcome to images in video the
killer use case for cloud storage I'm
Dave Eliot product lead responsible for
storage here in Google's cloud platform
my background is storage and storage in
the enterprise we're here today to talk
with you about some of the unique
challenges in storing and accessing
media and some innovative solutions from
Google
I'm Jeff Kimber and I'm a cloud
solutions architect I've had the
pleasure of working at different
companies such as ILM Pixar Framestore
and Blizzard I'm here to chat with you
today about some of the media
requirements as well as different use
cases from customers great so let's get
started so today's agenda we'll start
with Jeff sharing his experiences in
dealing with media and sharing some key
requirements for storing and accessing
video images and audio files then I'll
introduce object storage and cloud
storage and discuss how they are
well-suited to media assets next I'll
briefly to talk a little bit about
Google Cloud storage and how its
differentiated from other cloud object
stores and we'll finish with a few
examples of where Google Cloud Storage
is used today Jeff I want to take it
absolutely Dave so I spent most of my
career dealing with large files of
disparate types and sizes and one of the
defining aspects for me of media files
is just how many files you can have you
have many many small files you in very
very large files you can have files that
derive other files so if you have a
Mezen a file for instance for streaming
you'll have the entire film and then
you'll have to produce 28 different
flavors of it you'll have to make
different bit rates different
resolutions different codecs for
different platforms and all of that
storage is challenging to predict in
size more complex though is the fact
that users now have 4k cameras in their
pocket and they're shooting video
there's applications that are running on
all the platforms that are just
ingesting a massive amount of content
and when we talk about media files we're
talking about not just video but but I
assume audio and images as well there's
a lot of similarities across all of
those types of files right correct yeah
so from a media standpoint I've been
working with audio files tons of imagery
video files
and various hybrids of those different
types and the source files can be kept
in multiple versions and then recombined
so you end up having multiple versions
of the various files in different stages
of production that's one of the size
growth scalability issues guys so size
growth scalability one of the kind of
defining features of all types of media
okay great great
so what else do you seen with media
there it's growing it's growing rapidly
so what well how's it translate into a
requirement for storage well we made a
transition from standard F to hi-def
many years ago and everything is pretty
much 1080p now and moving forward though
a 4k is caught on in the last couple of
years we're seeing that it's not a fad
it's an actual growth trend for us
customers are paying for 4k content it's
not a fad
all right not a fad customers are also
interested in HDR and the standard will
be ratified before long that will
provide even more color depth and that
basically gives you greater film like
looks in terms of shadow detail and
brightness the image looks quite a bit
more lifelike than standard imagery does
today on so these consume enormous
amounts of storage eyes absolutely when
you go up in resolution and then when
you go up in color depth you very
quickly grow the size of the files
significantly and that is yet another
type of flavor that you need to make
when you're producing a video streaming
archive for ok ok so growth huge issue
so I assume scalability then is a
significant requirement and we're
talking about designing cloud or
designing storage architectures for
media so what else is important
protection right security is key you
need to ensure that only you have access
to the data and only the people you
grant access to have access to the
specific bits of data you want an
example would be if you have a massive
data archive that is proprietary to your
company you want to ensure that you can
provide distribution for elements of
that and have great controls over who
gets at that data and of course no one
else does so access control encryption
and things like that are important when
you're storing these very very valuable
assets yes what about what about just
generally what losing the assets what
about durability right it becomes very
expensive to have multiple copies and
manage multiple copies from our versions
syncing standpoint such so having a
highly durable single points
is lovely paying someone else to manage
that storage for you extremely valuable
when you do it on Prem you end up having
high availability storage you have
cooler storage you have mountains of
tapes that are stored both on Prem and
in cold storage off and imagine this is
how a lot of companies do it today so
high durability is a key requirement you
likely and companies today likely have
multiple replicas in order to meet that
durability requirement they're often
contractually required to have three
depending on the type of work
what about availability how important is
that yeah availability is critical on
the project that you may be working on
having the media available to you
randomly is key if it takes you hours to
be able to pull the data back or even
days if you have to online the data from
tape and the tape may not be on-premises
it takes hours to get it or up to
potentially three days to get the data
back overnight online it look at it and
realize you didn't restore enough of it
or you restored too much of it and
therefore it took too long to restore
and there's often dependencies that are
found in that restored data that then
point to other data that you then have
to repeat the process
so on-demand on-demand availability is
key correctly and that was only a local
restore you know you're then in a
scenario where if some if you have a
global office elsewhere and the data is
not local to them you have to work with
the timezone of that local office to get
that data back and then ship it to where
you want or imagine a consumer that's in
India might want to listen to a music
file or someone who's in Paris may want
to see an image a photograph that this
stored some rich media file asset and so
the ability to have that on-demand
access globally yes is important yeah
consumers are definitely focused on
getting things on demand and globally I
mean the web services all provide that
today great great and then you also I
know you also talked a little bit about
the importance from an availability
standpoint of just generally knowing
what the heck you have right yes I've
worked with customers who have large
vaults and I'm talking a cabinet with
hard drives in them and there'll be
handwritten post-it notes with an
elastic band around yeah and that's the
limit of the knowledge of the data and
they said yes the people who wrote those
notes aren't here anymore but we've
passed it down over time and that's
that's unfortunate in the fact that how
to get at that data you literally have
to take that hard drive and mount it in
a machine that has the correct interface
and then is hopefully running the right
OS
to be able to pull that data off and
then you have to sift through it that's
a horribly expensive task in terms of
human time and so the question is
whether or not that data actually gets
read again so the value of that data may
be really high but the usefulness of it
the value of it though to you the IP
owner is really low and the fact you
can't get at it because it cost us I got
it so a rich metadata model might be
something that would be valuable so that
you can describe these media assets in a
rich way and be able to have easy access
and essentially better availability to
them absolutely great great okay so
we've heard I guess to summarize what
I've heard as scalability is important
yes
mutti files are growing incredibly fast
flexibility so you need to be able to
support small files and large files you
need to be able to self describe the
files or have the files described in
some way with rich metadata security
protection durability and then generally
availability are important yes yeah the
global availability is the really the
exciting bit it's been challenging
working in the field with multiple
offices globally and you're having to
rely on file synchronization dedicated
links multiple file systems in each of
the disparate offices that then require
a synchronization that there's a lot of
overhead there's there's multiple people
required to make sure that system works
with a central global repository you can
just have individuals access the data
they need for me that's super exciting
from an availability standpoint
fantastic fantastic so now that we've
chatted some about the interesting
requirements for storage and storing
media I'd like to touch on object
storage and cloud storage and how those
fit many of the requirements that Jeff
just mentioned then I'll introduce cloud
storage and provide a brief overview of
how Google Cloud Storage is different so
a blob store an object store is a
storage architecture that manages data
as objects versus a storage architecture
like a file system which manages data as
a file hierarchy or block storage which
manages data as blocks within sectors or
tracks so two tenets of object storage
they make them popular choice for
managing media and media assets are
first there are a flat flexible and
scalable system so traditional storage
as I mentioned relies on a file system
hierarchies which creates certain upper
on scalability and performance object
storage doesn't have that limitation as
Jeff mentioned scalable performance is a
critical aspect of storing and accessing
media files object stores also provide
flexibility on the size of objects
second thing is object stores provide a
robust and flexible metadata layer
metadata capabilities as objects are
stored with the data they also have an
address and this robust and flexible
metadata so the meta Bey of flexibility
compared to other types of storage
addresses some of the accessibility
concerns that Jeff mentioned earlier
more metadata means better access and
better control so object storage isn't
perfect it doesn't solve all problems
but it does bring simplicity and
flexibility to access a scale for
storing media files if you understand
object storage and why it's such a
popular choice I'd like to touch a
little bit now on object storage in the
cloud object storage in the cloud adds
additional benefits such as first scale
becomes global Jeff talked about scale
and how critical it was scale becomes
global with global data centers so the
larger the cloud the more capacity you
can use to store your media assets that
may come during periods of unpredictable
growth so Google manages one of the
largest clouds in the world supports
many many mini exabytes of storage next
object storage in the cloud can be more
available so major cloud providers
provide data centers all over the globe
at Google we have more than a hundred
edge locations in 33 countries data will
stay online which is a stark in stark
contrast to tape storage also data can
be accessed with simple restful api
third cloud storage should be could be
and likely is more durable a
well-constructed cloud will deliver
highly redundant geographically diverse
storage in the case of Google Cloud
storage we offer 11 9s durability across
all tiers of object storage and finally
a well-constructed cloud should be even
more secure while a few years ago some
people believed cloud was less secure
because they didn't manage security
themselves today I think most people
agree that a well-run cloud provider
benefits from have
very very large and very focused team
providing security at Google we've got
something like more than 600 people
whose job it is to protect our cloud
infrastructure so overall is with with
any cloud any cloud service much of the
heavy lifting is designed is designing a
durable secure scalable clouds out
sourced so let's you focus on what
you're doing best what would you say
Jeff that that those key requirements
scalability durability availability are
some of the key tenets that people who
are managing and media assets are
looking for absolutely the opportunity
to be able to get at any file any time
super valuable the example I can give
would be I was on a production where we
had to get there's a directorial change
and they needed access to a file it
never happens never happens directors
never change their mind so in that
context we needed to bring an asset back
online that had been moved off of the
fast storage essentially and the version
was available but we had to we had to
pull it back and it was going to take
about a day and a half to get that data
just because it was in another office
and such so when I moved to another firm
where a hundred percent of the data was
online in terms of archival we were able
to restore the data back in just a
couple of minutes you could just change
your shot directory go over to where you
needed to find the file and pull it back
and that emulates the exact work use
model that we have for Google cloud
platform you can go and pull the files
back in just a couple of seconds and you
have access to the entire data set so
that the cost savings on on the several
days of people time and schedule time
wall clock as we call it was huge great
yeah yeah I've heard that story
it's actually those stories over and
over again it's the accessibility
availability to the data and then what
you can do with it in the time that you
save in trying to pull that data back is
one of the key benefits of having an
object store and having a cloud object
store absolutely when you look at the
total cost of ownership for on-premise
storage in terms of people time and the
number of days if you're on a schedule
of any kind and you have even add up the
salaries of all the people and add that
to your total cost of overhead and every
day you takes you longer to complete it
because you're pulling storage either
you're offline you're on online
to try and find it that's all real cost
great great so we've talked a little bit
about the requirements for for media and
managing media files and media assets we
then moved on and talked a little bit
about how objects tour is a different
approach that is really meets a lot of
those requirements and then how cloud
object store is it is really a even
better approach so if you're managing
media assets or if you will in the
future I guess
I guess you may ask the question you
know why Google and what what's unique
about Google so now I'd like to
transition into how Google and Google
Cloud Storage is different
Google's had to cope with massive
amounts of data because of its granite
scale
Google services are truly global
generating exabytes and exabytes of data
a secret to Google is continuing success
gene stems from the fact that Google is
able to operate at this scale before
anyone else and at price points order of
magnitudes less expensive than
competitors so as a result there are a
few distinct advantages to our scale and
our experience Google Cloud Storage lets
you store your media assets on our
global globally available highly secure
and efficient infrastructure our object
store is differentiated in several ways
first we deliver massive massive
scalability have I said that yet you're
the massive scalability have I said lots
and lots of exabytes yeah many many many
many can't tell you exactly but many
many many I'm growing rapidly we've as
much capacity as anyone needs one
customer came to us a while ago and
asked for several hundred petabytes
because they couldn't procure storage
quickly enough and they said they were
they wanted to grow into maybe a couple
of exabytes now as a storage guy that's
a lot of storage that is an unbelievable
amount of storage and we honestly didn't
have any concerns no when they asked how
many you know if they could have an
extra byte of data we could arrogantly
respond with how many exabytes would you
like yes exactly second our global
network our global network is a huge
differentiator
we've got built-in EdgeCast capabilities
where we keep your data on our network
as long as we possibly can and we
automatically store replicas
near where objects are most frequently
requested so this means better
availability and hence a better user
experience customer experience with your
media assets our network as I mentioned
before has more than a hundred edge
locations in 33 countries for caching
and you'll be tested on this 133 quiz
and we're the only cloud 2 provider that
actually has laid fibre of lead cables
across both oceans so can you talk a
little bit about the use case I have
data in Europe and I want to read it in
America and then I want to read it in
Singapore as well you talk a little bit
about how the buckets work and well well
really it comes down to you know a key
differentiator as we talk about the guys
you talked about the requirements for
media assets to be global in nature
right the person in India or Chicago or
Singapore needing access to these right
because the work is often done in
multiple locations and delivered
elsewhere or the customer or the
customer is in multiple locations you
may be web serving you may be serving
serving out images or you may be serving
out videos right the customer might be
in various locations and because we have
our own network we own our network it's
one of the huge advantages we've created
a we we've been pioneers in creating
ways to optimize best optimize data
movement you know across large distances
so for a customer that does have a
global operation that wants global
access to their data that's really one
of our to you know key differentiators
in addition to the to the network
we also are optimized for reading very
large files so we've optimized for
server side throughput means we simply
are faster and reading large files and
and this really comes from our legacy in
YouTube and photos and Google Play and
that means that your customers have a
better experience when they use your
media the fourth reason is our pricing
it's both low and simple to understand
we have frequently declining prices as
opposed to say you know again as a
storage guy purchasing storage hardware
that it's going to be capitalized over
three years and on average were 13 to
15% lower than our closest cloud
competitor and you know the thing the
feedback that I get so much from
customers is just much simpler to
understand the fifth
major thing I'll call out for Google
Cloud Servers differentiators is what
I'm just calling value-added services it
could be applied against your data when
it's in our cloud you know this goes
back to your accessibility comment
earlier Jeff where you know if you if
you can leverage if you could apply
systems against services against the
data you can create more value for your
customers so massive scalability global
network large read file throughput
pricing and these value-added services
which I'll let you talk about in a
couple minutes makes sense it does great
so I just briefly wanted to introduce
Google Cloud Storage the actual service
itself we've got three flavors standard
durable reduced availability and
Nearline storage they all come with
eleven ninth durability target and they
primarily differ in price and
availability standard storage offers
99.9 percent availability SLA it's ideal
for workloads that require a performance
availability and durability so it's sort
of the standard or maybe the premium one
durable reduced availability is exactly
what it says it's highly durable and it
has a slightly reduced availability SLA
at 99% so it's ideal for workloads that
can accept the occasional unavailability
so for instance batch workloads finally
Nearline storage is our newest storage
offering and this is ideal ideally
designed as a cool storage pool this is
only a penny a gig per month but comes
with a penny read penalty per gig and
it's ideal for in frequently accessed
media such as a backup files or even
archive files so with that Jeff I'd love
for you to talk about that fifth thing I
mentioned on the previous slide which
was the value added services so we
talked a lot about the benefits of
moving to an object stores been instead
moving to a cloud and benefits moving to
two Google's infrastructure but where I
think a lot of excitement is today is
what can you do with the data once it's
in the cloud once it's in our cloud
absolutely one of the really cool things
about Google is the leadership and the
lead that we have in machine learning
technology it is not an overly exciting
conversation to say what
a gig cost and hey wait hold on a second
well it can't be but for me what's more
compelling is things let the cloud
Translate API that we have the ability
to have 80 plus languages available you
can put one language in Auto language
detection you can get another language
out and that works across both text as
well as speech so we have a cloud speech
API and that will allow you to have both
batch as well as streaming audio so you
can as people are familiar with talking
to your phone that can be in one
language we can do a translate to text
for that we can do a a or a actual
language translation with that and using
the cloud natural language API we can
then do a context awareness of what was
said what was relevant about that and be
able to deconstruct the language and get
the sentiment of what the user is
looking for so this sounds like a corner
case it sounds like something that may
not apply to a lot of people but the
concept that there's this service that's
really innovative service that you're
applying now against your data that you
otherwise couldn't have done if we're
just sitting on tape somewhere I think
that's really compelling absolutely yeah
from an imagery standpoint I'd encourage
you to download Google photos it's free
it's available for iOS and Android
you can choose to compress your images a
little bit with JPEG and there's no
limit on what you can upload if you
choose that option the nice thing about
it is you can put thousands and many
many thousands of images up and the
server on the back end will do the
metadata analysis for you so if you type
in Golden Gate Bridge or you type in cat
or you know any of the search terms for
imagery that you may have you'd be
amazed at the accuracy and the speed
with which the imagery can be presented
to you so that the vision API is
fantastic you can feed it a significant
amount of imagery and get back highly
relevant scored metadata and it comes to
you with a percentage of accuracy it
includes face detection it includes
emotion and you can decide if someone is
as angry or sad or pensive there's all
sorts of you know different complexities
built in and built into the model you
can show it an image of two kittens and
it'll tell you what kind of kittens they
are it's it's a really really compelling
use case but what's interesting to me is
taking a
massive multipad abite or multi hundred
petabyte archive that you may have and
on lining that under the cloud and then
running metadata analysis against it
with the vision API that allows you to
then get at that data it becomes
catalogued it becomes useful you're able
to monetize that and you're able to
either resell it or make it available to
consumers or make it available to your
employees and the company depending the
type of data and that's just the current
roadmap of what we have there's more
products coming soon
backed by our machine learning
technology we also have big query and
big data analytics Google is extremely
adaptive handling large amounts of data
with huge numbers of queries per second
to be able to data mined and come up
with relevant responses on massive data
sets the queries you have so if you have
large data that you want to work with
please use our tools they're really
fantastic
in addition we also offer transcoding
for media use cases if you have images
or video that is in one format you need
it in another we offer everything from
roll your own ffmpeg solutions to fully
managed backed solutions with partners
and the transcoding use case again is
especially compelling it runs extremely
well on our per minute cloud and the
massive amount of storage we have means
you can transcode everything in parallel
and be able to deliver it globally thank
you so these are some good examples of
once you move your data to the cloud you
can apply things like with Shuren
machine learning analytics you can can
potentially apply other innovative
services that are coming from Google in
the future that really creates some
differentiation based upon your data
absolutely you can also roll your own as
well our open source tensorflow product
is all open source you can download it
make your own graphs and you can run
your own models against your data as
well yeah we're all about open so if you
want to run containers locally and then
run them on data you have in the cloud
that that's fully portable great great
so so we've talked about some of the
differentiators of GCS and now now let's
let's take a second and dive into or at
least talk a little bit about so how are
customers actually using this I mean
who's using Google Cloud Storage who's
using cloud stores generally object
store you know are there are they
managing media files and and what kind
of companies are doing that great well
we have Vimeo which is a very popular
video streaming service we have snapchat
for social media we have Spotify for
music streaming Ubisoft for gaming we
have Wix for websites we have ignite for
file sharing Khan Academy that everyone
is familiar with some fantastic large
videos available there
in addition JDI for file sharing as well
great great so those are some great
brand names that are using Google Cloud
storage for for for storing there and
managing their media assets so I mean
with that let's talk a little bit about
about next steps so if you're managing
media assets or if you will in the
future where to get started
so there's several patterns we've seen
on how people get started using Google
Cloud storage for managing their media
assets first serving globally so our
multi regional jewel redundant storage
lightning fast Network
large file we read throughput
performance and scale make GCS an ideal
storage pool for serving media files
second transcoding transcoding and data
processing so our regional DRA ability
to burst workloads again our global
network our and Votto services make this
great for some of those services that
Jeff mentioned earlier layering on top
of your media files and third archiving
its asset recovery so with low
predictable price including no ingress
fees consistent set of api's across all
three tiers and an instant on-demand
access make this an ideal service for
archiving and disaster recovery that's
an excellent point with Nearline we've
we've reduced the latency down so it's
it's incredibly quick it's it's under a
second for read and we've also removed
the throttling on egress so the larger
the size of pipe you have the more
quickly obviously we can sense him the
data to you and that high predictability
allows you to know what it would cost if
you want to bring back 400 terabytes of
data you know how long it'll take and
you know what it'll cost and that's
really important in a dr scenario that
exactly right it's not just a question
of a low of low price or low cost of
storing up
your assets for a long period of time
but the fact that you have
predictability on on recovery is a key
aspect that customers seem to really
like so with that I'm going to wrap up
if you're managing media if you're
managing media assets cloud storage
Google Cloud Storage offers you a
low-cost solution that can scale scale
scale lets you focus on what you do best
to differentiate your business the great
thing about cloud is it's easy to try
I recommend the try train and engage
process information is plentiful online
and we're here to help you be successful
thanks for joining us today thanks for
watching
you